hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide today I'm going to be
showing you how you can make about uh
900 to 1 mil an hour just by doing The
Gnome restaurant miname it's a bit of a
hidden method people don't really play
this mini game very much and the reason
behind that is it's a little bit
complicated to begin with uh but once
you get this set up it's really easy to
do no risk involved and you can do it at
a very low level
okay so we're going to start this mini
game uh at this gnome in the uh North
Western corner of the first floor of the
Grand Tree his name is Gian Jr now when
you start off uh talking to Gian you'll
have to do uh two kind of introductory
Parts just to show you how this Min game
works and what you're going to have to
do is create uh five pieces of food for
this guy and then there's another gnome
in the South right corner I'll show you
um that that uh you need to make some
drinks for so the way this mini game
works and how you make money from it is
mainly from one specific item and that
is the gnome
scarf so the gnome scarf is obtainable
from two of the potential delivery
targets so not all of them so
essentially what we're going to want to
do is only deliver to those two Targets
unfortunately that's not available when
you first start doing the mini game by
the way here's the other guy down here
you're going to be trading uh they sell
you the supplies that you're going to
need for the mini games uh but you'll
have to run and talk to this guy uh to
finish up the kind of mini quest to
begin the actual um mini game so how are
we to skip uh to get the proper delivery
targets and that is going to be by
playing the mini game for a little while
legitly so to do this method you really
only require 42 cooking uh 10
construction and really trome Village
you don't actually need any requirements
but to really do this effectively you'll
need those any uh other recommended
requirements would be doing the Grand
Tree Quest fairy tales part two uh
higher magic level for any
teleportations and while These are nice
they are not required at all uh they'll
only speed up this first process of
unlocking the ability to skip to
whatever Target you want uh but again
you won't need them after that but it
does save you a lot of time so what
you're going to do is uh start by
completing orders and the way you do
that is you talk to the Gian Jor uh at
first he's uh going to give you a little
bit of a different text message uh but
yes delivering is fun you're going to
want to do to the edge of the world is
no limit for alof alof food deliveries
and that is essentially saying you're
doing a hard order and now the hard
orders have about 12 or 13 targets of
those 13 targets
two of those is what you want so you get
a Target and I'll link the wiki article
cuz there would be too much to talk
about all the targets and how to make
all the food but essentially what you're
going to do is just uh find The Gnome
and deliver the piece of food that is
required uh mixing the food is pretty
easy you just have to combine the
ingredients together and then you drop
it off okay so now we'll just do a
sample delivery here so we've gone and
gotten a
order uh it says Captain CLM foodle
wants a short green guy
uh now making the drinks in orders uh
takes a little while but what I've done
is I've stockpiled three of each one so
that way I can easily withdraw and if I
run out I just make three more of the
item that I ran out of seems a little
more time efficient that way uh so Clen
foodle that is the kja pilot so most of
these are pretty easily accessible now
if there's one you can't do uh you can
just wait 5 minutes and get a new
order um so it's not a huge deal and I
wouldn't go out of your way just to get
the requirement cuz once you um I've
done this for about 2 hours you won't
need any of those requirements anymore
so we're going to come up here uh just
do this quickly talk to this guy we'll
go to the glider um you'll get used to
where all these uh gnomes reside but you
again you won't really have to worry
about this after you're going to talk to
him after you brought him to
drink and he's going to give you a
reward so he gave me three toad flax not
bad uh now the important thing here is
you can see these credits uh now I've
already maxed out all the credits I can
get you get three credits per
delivery and uh once you get 12 credits
you're going to get a piece of gnome
food delivered to you now for whatever
reason once you get yours up to 10 items
it brings up a different
chat uh type for when you start your
food deliveries and that will let you
skip the orders right away uh which I'll
show you here and it doesn't require you
to wait any time so you can literally
spam it until you get the two gnomes
that you want those gnomes are captain
ninto and Captain darkin one is at the
Dual Arena and one is
below uh White Wolf Mountain it's the
area where the fishing contest uh Quest
unlocks okay so now that uh you have
filled up your reward tokens it'll take
about 40 regular deliveries which will
probably take about 2 hours now you
notice he says clearly you're a very
hard worker I think you need a holiday
um and what you can do now is say yes to
leing is
fun and then you get an
order okay it's Bramble bck uh this
guy's way out of the way we definitely
don't want to do that one so you just
talk to him
again yes L room is
fun and you can do it over and over
again until you get the right gnome and
then the easiest way to do this is just
Spam space bar and then click the chat
options you kind of get good that after
a while still don't want that one and
then essentially just do it until you
get the right gnome go do those two
deliveries one is at the Dual Arena and
one is below White Wolf Mountain and
then you have a pretty good chance of
getting a scarf which is worth about
800k and it's about a 1 in 20 chance so
before I start my 1 hour of doing The
Gnome restaurant I'm just going to
quickly show you the easiest way to get
to the two gnomes you're going to
actually be going to
uh the first is Captain ninto the
easiest way I found by far is to just
set your house to uh Taverly uh which
you need 10 construction for and then
you're just going to run a little bit up
here to the left and it's very close
very easy and that's way better than
running from Camelot which you can do as
well uh but that requires a higher magic
level and it just generally takes longer
and he's just going to be right in here
and that's how you get to the first
gnome uh the next one easiest way by far
is to just go to the Dual arena with a
ring of
dueling once you arrive uh just run up
onto the stands and he's kind of in the
middle uh not too far away but you kind
of do have to kind of get right into the
Dual Arena all right so here is Captain
durken right in the middle here uh you
can see just a little bit east of where
the Dual ring uh pops you off and there
he is now on top of that the easiest way
I found to get back to the gr tree is to
just have ring of wealth teleport to the
gr Exchange
and then run a little bit Northeast to
the spirit tree sorry and uh then just
go back to n stronghold alternatively
you can also use the ardun cloak one uh
which you require the diary for but it's
not too hard to get and it has an
limited amount of teleports and you just
teleport uh to the arj monastery and
then you just run a little bit up
here and there's a tree there a little
bit less quick but also doesn't require
any charges or anything pretty easy to
do all right guys so we've started this
method off uh we're on to our first
delivery uh if we can find the dwarf he
sometimes hides us around here quite a
bit all right delivery number two is
going to get
us three Opals that's not very good
delivery number three four I don't even
know anymore uh it's going to get us
nine sapphires not too bad our next
delivery is going to get us a bird's
nest that's kind of interesting we'll
see what we get at that for that after
I'm going to say delivery number six is
going to be three emeralds not too bad
delivery number seven also to ninto is
going to be three rubies H that's
actually decently valuable I mean
compared to the other drops next
delivery is going to be 10 sapphires not
too bad all right next delivery is to
ninto and it's going to net us two opal
is pretty shitty actually Jades even
worse another delivery to ninto is going
to get us a diamond I guess that's not
terrible uh delivered to darkin finally
is uh two Jades that's pretty shitty
again all right we got another delivery
to ninto H he's right beside me there
please give me the scarf buddy I've done
like eight deliveries so far 10 come
on it's going to be three emeralds maybe
next time all right another delivery to
ninto maybe this time we give me the
scarf and it's two Jades again all right
Durkin come on give me the scarf it's
going to be three Opals come on all
right Durkin another delivery to him
it's going to be some emeralds so H
three emeralds not too bad our next
delivery is going to get us a red topaz
I don't even know how much that's worth
all right another delivery to ninto is
going to get us oh there we go there's a
scarf sweet uh it's a pretty awesome
scarf but mainly is worth 800k roughly
uh so that's pretty good I think we only
have like uh 15 10 minutes left so it's
kind ofce we got that in the hour and
there we go that's
811k all right we got the scarf so
anything after this is kind of just
gravy uh but we are going to get a uh
Snap Dragon not too bad all right
another delivered to ninto uh come on
another scarf please three toe FL not
too bad actually all right we're nearing
the end I think we might be able to do
one more delivery after this uh so four
emeralds not too bad and yeah we'll be
able to squeeze one more in I think all
right and our last delivery is to Durkin
come on let's just get another scarf
just for the LOLs and that's a
jade oh well we still got our scarf so
we're pretty happy all right guys we're
at the ground exchange and this is what
we manag to get in 1 hour we got a scarf
18 emeralds a bird's nest which we'll
open in a second here uh let's search it
uh we get a willow seed of the bird's
nest so I know not too bad and we'll go
ahead and price check this it's going to
be worth about
900k uh now keep in mind there's a
couple other drops we could have gotten
mainly the grand seed pod now if you get
that that is a mill drop it's pretty
rare uh but it is still worth factoring
in uh even if we only got that
every 5 hours that's still an extra 100
200k an hour uh it is a rare drop but
you do get it and when you do you can
get I think five to 10 of them uh so
it's not likely but you can get it
eventually so we'll go ahead and sell
the scarf for 813k sell the rest of the
stuff and we'll come back and uh see how
much we profited uh for this 1 hour of
gnome
restaurant all right guys everything's
sold uh The Gnome scarf only took about
20 minutes to sell honestly really
quickly what collect and see how much
money we managed to make uh looks like
910k so not bad uh keep in mind if uh
you factor in the fact that there is a
couple other rare drops you can get I
would say this is easily 1 mil an hour
over the
longterm uh which is pretty good
considering there's no risk it's pretty
low requirements and uh it's not too
click intensive except for skipping the
tasks is a little
Annoying all right guys thanks for
watching and I will see you guys in the
next next video
[Music]